hi
uh chris carlson here with jose martin
garcia
i'm a user interface developer and jose
is in the algorithms
r d group and we're going to tell you
about what's happening with
dataset i'm the developer of
things concerning the front-end
interface aspects of dataset
and jose works under the hood so to
speak on
the computational aspects of dataset
so what what we're going to be
describing is um
these projects are underway right now
and will be rolled out sometime
after 12.2
so uh because they're in progress
you uh and your comments can um
can have an effect on the course of the
development so
we would like to hear from you your
comments and
questions so please direct those to the
chat and then
at the end of the talk we'll we'll
address those
so um for those who
may not be real familiar with dataset
let me just give a brief introduction
dataset is the main
concept in wolfram language for dealing
with structured data sets
which by which i mean nested lists and
associations
so here is a data set which is a list of
associations
and you get the list elements going down
as rows
and each column corresponds to one of
the elements of the
association so
some functions in wolfram language will
return data sets
as their return values
there is some interactive behavior on
data sets they
they scroll um you can drill down
and back up and so forth but for the
most part they're
output only so the the first project
that i want to talk about
is um data set editing
and i have a prototype that i can that i
can show you
briefly so
here's a data set and
in the prototype i'll say i'll click
here edit
333 and return and i've done a quick
spot edit of that value
now in this prototype it pops out a
dialog window but in the final product
it'll be editing in place
um and the way that you initiate an edit
will probably be by way of like a menu
bar that pops up
when you hover over the data set for
something similar
so you can't you will have
complete access to navigation whoops
what's going on here this is not
evaluating
there's something odd going on hang on
just a second
it is
well i i don't know what's going on here
for some reason it's not
it's not giving me any outputs let me
let me
open this talk open this talk anew
oh here we go okay i don't know what was
going on there
all right so uh there's
full navigation while you're editing so
if i
say your edit i'm tabbing through here
and then you can scroll and edit
drill down and edit
and so forth so all of those edits are
reflected then in
the data set
data set displays some things uh
in special forms for example quantities
are not displayed as quantity but they
have this special form within data set
when you edit everything is displayed in
input form
otherwise some of these things would be
impossible to edit
so you you can you have access to both
the
uh the quantities and the
the amounts and the units when you're
editing similarly for other things like
geolocation or those kinds of things
if you have an item display function
so item item display function
is a function you can interpose between
the content of the data set and the way
it's displayed
so if you have an item display function
and edit it shows you the underlying
content and then when you're done
editing it it pops back in
and applies item display function
if you edit an item completely away
then the resulting value is missing
and if i go back and out of this one now
you can see that it's inserted that
missing value which
you can replace with another edit
as i said there's navigation
while you're editing sometimes it allies
items if i
drill down here to b well
you can see there's a bc which has been
alighted
um when you're editing you can navigate
down to
the alighted items to edit those as well
so with the possibility of editing data
sets
by using placeholder you can essentially
use sets as input
forms so probably in the
in the finished project if there's a
placeholder you click on the placeholder
it'll automatically
bring up the editor but you can
now i can tab through here and enter
values
as if i'm doing entry in a form
okay so that's that's data set editing
now let's talk about data set themes
so themes may be familiar to some of you
from
plot themes and data set themes are
analogous to plot themes
so here is a default plot
and if i add plot theme
marketing
then that pulls in a coordinated set of
options that give
the marketing style and
these can also have sub
themes like large labels
that you can fine-tune
the plot themes so we're going to apply
the same
idea to data set and uh
this this is not yet prototypes but this
is the proposal
so these are the uh basic themes which
are analogous to the plot themes for
data
set giving you minimal classic
monochrome and so forth data set themes
and then we're also discussing a number
of additional themes
for example like these uh line line
printer paper
uh i remember what a line printer is i
don't know if
everybody listening does but uh that has
indexed rows and columns that makes it
easier to follow
in in long rows and columns uh a heat
map for example
um which uh color codes the
value and the cell here's a tool tip
heat map
which is the heat map where the values
are hidden but are revealed by tool tips
histogram for example where values are
indicated by
bar charts so i'm especially interested
if if
any of you have requests or ideas for
plot themes mention that in the chat and
we'll talk about that
after the talk and
like all dataset options that affect
style you can apply a plot or a data set
theme
to a sub part of the data set so for
example
here i've said i want to apply the
histogram theme
to the age column and that gives me bars
here and
i don't want to apply a hypothetical
check mark theme to the survive column
to translate it and check marks
okay that's what there is to say about
editing and themes i'll
hand it over to jose who will talk about
improvements to the type
system sorry it was muted
so i'm going to be talking about ongoing
work on
the type system of data set
so data set needs a type system because
it's
fundamental in the choice of layout of
the result
and also to perform faster queries
so the type system is stored as
second argument of data set and
it has its own language in a context
called type system i have added the
the context to the um context path
so that we don't see continuously data
set backtake or
typeset backtake objects and
um yes
and something else i wanted to point out
is that as we
discussed in the conference last year we
have removed
the id components in the third argument
that were problematic when comparing two
uh data sets that were identical in
a content and therefore type uh but not
in the in ids so
so now this works in a different way and
so what we do
is that the third argument is now used
to store
the options and option values of data
set
like here the background color
okay so some properties of the type
system of
data set it's a towel type system
oriented towards the types of elements
in arrays possibly ragged arrays it's
not a general type system for example
when working with data set we don't need
to worry about function types
so it's not as general as the compiler
type system for example
but it goes into a lot of detail
in for for the tabular data
it focuses in controlling fundamentally
lists and associations
and everything else are considered atoms
and there are special cases that right
now
are still considered atomic like special
race and series
or even data sets themselves but that
may change in in the future to convert
this into
also specially treated
array containers of data containers
so i want to very briefly show a few
examples
of of types
the main function is a function in the
time type system context called deduce
type
in this context and for
for something like three it will return
atom of
integer where this atom is again
something in the
type system contents for a string it
will return string
for quantities and entities it stores
part of the information
the the units in this case or the domain
in the case of units
and for other expressions it returns any
type
now for lists it will do something like
this
for a list like this it will say that we
have
four integers and vector means
homogeneous list
this is a this is a homogeneous list in
which all elements
are integers if we have nested lists
it will effectively works work like
dimensions
so we have two and a homogeneous list
of two yes a homogeneous list of two
elements
each of them being a homogeneous list of
length three
of integers if the
array is rugged then we have something
like this we have two lists
containing lists of integers of
different lengths
and then we have this symbol here any
length
and if the list is not homogeneous
then we have this different object
called tuple which will list
the the the types
of the individual objects
okay that's what we do for lists so the
main thing is to distinguish homogeneous
lists
for from inhomogeneous lists
and for associations something similar
happens
we have a homogeneous association
of integers integer values three of them
and when the
when the list of keys is short enough
then we enumerate them if if if it
becomes too long or long i think there
is a threshold
at around 16 or something like that
then this will just say string
and if the association is inhomogeneous
then we have another object
listing the keys and the types of the
values
so these are the elements of the data
set type system and they can be combined
in as obvious
in the obvious way
okay so because every computation with
typeset with datasets sorry
starts by every construction of a
dataset starts by computing the type
it's critical that this computation of
type is fast enough and so this has been
one of the main things
this year improving the speed of data
center
so to play with examples let's
use our planet's example data set
so this is the data it contains
internally so it's a bunch
of nested associations containing
quantities
and other associations and
it is 160k kilobytes so it's not
very large so if we compute the type
we get that actually it's a bit slower
because
sharing with zoom this becomes a bit
slower
but but yeah it it can do it in a
fraction of a second
but it's a small data set so
let's now go to a larger data set 160
megabytes now which is a thousand times
our data
and so we have find here two issues
apart from
two issues the first one is the
following
this takes now over a second which
for 160 megabytes might not be so bad
but
the problem we see here is that even
though this recognized
that it is a homogeneous list of
a thousand objects it actually didn't
give us the type we had found
before for the individual object
so uh yeah so these
the first element there is not the type
that we found before
and so this is something uh
that is not convenient the second thing
is that this actually didn't look at the
thousand
elements there there is a variable in
type system
called deduction window size 32 meaning
that the type type system is actually
looking at the first 32 and the last 32
rows so we are going to change that to
infinity
so that now we force reduce type to
actually look at the full object
and so this now becomes
slower and this is now becomes
a bit too slow
so we have a a new type system
and what we are it's right now it's it's
in the
it's called new that you type
reviews type and now
um we see we compute the type
of the original data uh
this is just to check that we get
exactly what we
were getting before and you see how
instead of
0.01 seconds this is now faster
and with the large data and this type
system is looking at the at the full
list of thousand elements
we get something under a second and you
see
the first element is also the type
that we had at the beginning so now this
stability condition
is obeyed i will comment in a moment why
we need this here for example just to
give you another
example this is a list containing a
million
numbers some expressions and another
million numbers again
so with the previous time system this
will take
um the order than i think of six seconds
and because it it realizes there are
mixed types it returns
any type and this is the length of the
object with a new type system this is
much faster now
or for example take the 249 countries of
the world as
entities now we choose like a million of
them
runner's choice and again
how long does it take to compute the
type of this object
it it's also a number of seconds
and if we do it with a new type system
this is
a lot faster now you may think
just to compare uh to give you a sense
of the speed of this
you might think this was just a matter
of extracting
all domains from all the entities and
then deleting duplicates
so if we time this operation we see that
it is
slower than this one so this gives you a
sense of the efficiency of
of the code here
now how do we use it with dataset itself
what i've done is since we introduced
the switch
so by default is false
which means that it is using the
previous time system
so as chris said this is uh
ongoing work and for 12 2 we are not
planning to activate
this new type system we want to test it
a lot more
but if you want to test it switch this
variable
and and yeah if you have comments or
let us know so these are you see
the timings the of construction of the
data set
related to the construction of of the of
the types
so now we activate it and we see
how this becomes now faster
for the two example sets that we
constructed before
now the new type system has a
couple of arguments a controlling
how much you want to report
about the system for example here this
eight
means this is the threshold between
homogeneity and homogeneity
for example in this case we decide that
eight is still good enough
to report
all the keys in an association but if
you say seven
then because there were eight
planets reported there it just gives you
a homogeneous association
saying well they are all strings we
don't care about the
the names the same something similar
happens with enumeration
so this additional argument it's going
to control whether you allow
enumeration or not by default it's
deactivated so effectively this is zero
but now here you say i want up to four
keys being enumerated and then you will
get
rather than string you will get
enumeration objects
so this is just a way to control the
thresholds
so that you get more or less information
and this
has an effect on the layout of dataset
for example let's these
deduction of of types can be applied to
arbitrary expressions that are arrays so
let's take for example
um the biggest polygon object that we
handle which is the
more than a quarter of a million points
so we can use
this to report what we have and so it
will report correctly
that we have 18 51
lists each of one being
lists of pairs of rails
that's what this means now we do it with
a new type system
we get the same result but faster
another example groupings so for example
this
we have this function groupings to
construct uh
combinatorial objects and
if we ask the the type system what this
is
it's it's effectively dimensions it's
just saying
we have 54 pairs but if we sort them
now we get more information because
we have more consistent structure we
have 54
pairs but now we have the information
that the first element is an integer
and the second is a pair of integers
right they are they all have been sorted
in elements of this form
so you see how these also becomes some
sort of
rugged dimensions so this generalizes
dimensions
to report more structure so this can be
useful analyzing i don't know the
internals of graphics or
whatever and then
i have a bigger object here again
let's evaluate it this will take a few
seconds to unload
so this is downloaded from the new york
times the
data updated to today of copy data for
all the counties
in the u.s so this is a data set
of again 100 nearly 160 megabytes
and so let's take just uh some random
choice and we see that
what we see here are lines of the form
string so date string string
this is some code for the county number
of cases number of deaths
so again
that data set with the
current type system with to take i mean
assuming we look at all the rows which
is what we have to do
to avoid missing some
incomplete information or incorrect
information
right so that's what it took and you see
it's a data set with this number of
lines
froze and so with the new one it takes
less than a second so
uh that's what i had prepared so
now um yes we will take
questions and as i said this will not be
by default
on the 12 2 but
if you try it please let us know and or
whether you find some case that you
think it
should be still faster
okay uh let's see we have questions
both either for me or for uh
chris yeah i've been
uh paying attention to the chat uh
window
there are lots of good suggestions thank
you for your comments
a lot of people asked about pivot tables
functionality
that's come up in our discussions about
a data set
it hasn't bubbled up to the top of the
priority list
but if it's apparent that there's large
demand for that
it could there have been other
suggestions for
labels on bars spark lines that's a
great one
search functionality and data set i've
i've made note of all of those things
and
we'll consider that some of you
have mentioned export issues for example
you export something just csv and it
gives you date objects
i uh i'll look into that export is not
you know
export happens kind of magically
and is done by another group but i'll
i'll check that out and follow up on
that
um let me just go back and have another
look at the chat window um there were a
couple of questions i think
um you could address jose about um
the type yes so i see a question here
about uh support for lots of quantities
inside
yes so the idea is
is to have different internal
representations given that data set is
atomic we can use the opportunity to
have internal representations
of things and so we now have a quantity
array
to and and other types of
structural rate to represent quantities
and
other things more efficiently so we will
be making use of that
and there was another question
yes missingness yes so the type system
uh the the new type system does
uh accept a fraction of the elements
being missing
and then it will explore the equivalent
cases
in other rows to deduce the type if
there is consistency
between the types of all other men of
all
other elements except for the missing
ones then it will
assume those missions had also those
types
um david brodas asked about zoom in and
zoom out
i presume what you mean is
to change the size of the scrolling
window
the number of things you see when you
scroll if so
yes that's one of the things that's on
the agenda is to
provide a resize thumb
in the corner of dataset output so you
can do that
i think our time is about up it's 12
uh there's one quick question what about
import export to pandas and data frames
um that is certainly something that we
should consider
and i'll make a note of that right
actually if you use the external
evaluate
about python and you import
pandas object then it automatically
comes as
a data set object
yeah so just one comment on on time
series yes we are working on
how to merge uh in a better way time
series and and
okay well i appreciate your comments
those are all uh very helpful really
a great um issues if anything else comes
up or you want to lobby
me or jose for some functionality send
email to carlson wolfram.com
and we'll give it a look thank you
thank you